hello everyone and welcome to today's
live broadcast f CMOS observations at
Swiss OGS presented by dr. Emiliano
cordially and dr. Ynez Yvonne ba ba
I'm Christy Jewell of lab rats and I
will be your moderator for today's event
today's educational web seminars brought
to you by laberd's and sponsored by
and/or for more information on our
sponsor please visit and/or calm
let's get started I want to remind
everyone that today's event is
interactive and we encourage you to
participate by submitting as many
questions as you want at any time you
want during the presentation to do so
simply type them into the ask a question
box and click send we will answer as
many questions as we have time for at
the end of the presentation
if you have any trouble seeing or
hearing the presentation just use that
ask a question box to let us know you're
experiencing a problem
today's webinar is educational and the
software's continuing education credits
just click on that continuing education
credits tab at the top of your screen
and follow the process to obtain your
credit
I would now like to introduce our first
speaker dr. Emilio no cord le
dr. cordeliers a researcher at the
astronomical Institute of the University
of Bern and currently in charge of
research and development at the Swiss
optical ground station and geo dynamics
observatory Zimmer world Swiss ogf his
areas of expertise include orbital and
attitude dynamics of artificial objects
covering also the orbit and attitude
determination of space debris
he has observational and analysis
experience of satellite laser ranging
astrometric and photometric measurements
for a complete biography on emiliano
please visit the biography tab at the
top of your screen
Emiliano you may now begin your
presentation
thanks Krista hello everybody today I
would like to talk to you about some
CMAs observation that we performed here
at the Swiss optical ground station
Jordan AMEX Observatory dimmable so just
a small presentation first the Sri
software ground station cha Dynamics
Observatory in Zimmer bar belongs to the
astronomy Institute of the University of
Burnham and here we perform research
activity focusing on the space debris on
special variants astrodynamics satellite
geodesy and global dynamics in order to
support his research activities the reso
GS is performing 24/7 basis of the
operation and what we are we are our
telescope during the night observe
especially space debris asteroids comets
supernovae while during daytime and
nighttime we have a satellite laser
ranging system and GPS receiver or
Genesis receiver working 24 hour per day
we of course being part of the
University we have also some teaching
module in astronomy so a short outline
of this talk I will briefly talk at the
beginning about the order that we are
using where the camera the CMOS camera
is integrated and which software we
needed to develop in order to to do some
particular observation and then I will
talk about the kind of observation that
were performing so we do some lucky
images some observation about asteroids
the camera is also used as a tracking
camera in parallel to the satellite
laser ranging activities then we were
able recently to extend our camera
observation also to daytime operation
and finally what we can get in terms of
space debris and now we can count this
measurement can be useful for orbit and
attitude determination
okay starting from the our turn
so all the observe Asian that we will
see later on are acquired with the
Timmerman laser and astronomy is an
Astra metre telescope it is one metre
class telescope it's pretty versatile
you have different experiment on going
on this telescope
we have as an example one could a path
for the satellite laser ranging system
then we have in the Nasmith platform we
have a four for gas station with
different focal lengths in one there is
a CCD camera in one there is a photon
counter detector that is just for
experimental use and we and this under
testing at the moment
and then today we will talk about mainly
the the operation that we perform on the
CMOS camera inside the CMOS camera is
running in parallel to the laser
observation we need to add the filter to
block the laser light rendered laser
light reaches the sensor because we
don't want to damage the camera and then
since we extended also the observation
during daytime we added also sky filter
to cut out the light of the sky as we
will see later so once again this is our
telescope some particular in front from
the back and we have the nasmyth
platform why there are feet flat for
means interesting for us because as we
can see here there is the camera
installed and just the particular here
you see how the camera fit and on the
right of the picture you have the focal
reducer we have the focal reducer for
more details about this camera I would
leave to leave the link to go to the
under website
what is interesting of just small
information the 22 millimeter diagonal
field of view of the camera allow on the
focal length that we use in the 8th
meter for the length the field of view
of 6x7 at minute it is important for the
hour for the application that we are
going to see now so starting with the
application we know being Research
Institute part of the University we are
also performing some educational
observation so in the right paw in the
right side of the slide we see and the
results of a series of images acquired
for the moon it seemed very nice to see
for student at least is very nice to see
the details the on the surface of the
Moon like craters and actually it's easy
from a picture measure the dimension of
the craters and with some much more we
can measure also the ID of the mountains
and of the crater knowing the position
of the Sun and the position and the
amount of the shadow that we see then
some funny tests where we perform at
some funny tests with the lucky imaging
actually we assume that the the
atmosphere is made by her lenses and if
you are lucky enough one of these lens
will be on top of your telescope and
will compensate the effect of your thing
delivering the source very sharp images
so this is the problem is that for 1
meter telescope to have 1 meter her lens
is a bit more rare so you don't have a
perfectly sharp image but nevertheless
here is interesting to see on the Left
picture the an image of the
International Space Station
from which you can distinguish one can
distinguish quite easily the body of the
of the space station and the solar
panels okay let's move for more let's
say scientific results so this is a an
example of the picture taken with the
CMOS camera when it was in the four
meter focal length the effective field
of view in fact is twelve by fourteen
half minutes we perform an observation
campaign of the asteroid 2012 TC 4
during its flyby around dirt actually
these are the light this this picture
was observed at the night of the 11th of
October and the satellite was sorry not
satellite the disaster either was
passing at a distance of forty four
thousand kilometers from the earth
in terms of astronomical distances this
is pretty close actually and it just it
was just 8,000 kilometers above the
geostationary ring that is one of the
most crowded the space region that we
use for human activities like television
and remote sensing a meteor observation
so what we can see in the centre of the
image we see the asteroid and then we
have also them limit that say one of the
faint we highlighted also one of the
faintest start that we could get with
using this camera and only two seconds
of exposure so but okay this is just a
picture now I will show you a video
about these disasters
you
from the analysis of this video we this
was not the only video that we acquired
that night actually is not really a
video we acquired the seventh series of
images each one containing containing
roughly 200 images spread over two hour
and 20 minutes if we analyze the
brightness variation of the light
reflected by the asteroid over T's image
series we get these segmented light
course nevertheless this segmented light
curve allowed us to perform a phase
reconstruction of the face
reconstruction procedure that allowed to
struct the phase diagram of deem of the
object that we can see on the right and
these are once we are able to get a
short phase diagram we are also able to
extract the rotation period of
testosterone this is very interesting
was knowing the phase diagram we can all
the stronger were inferring the shape of
the asteroid while we could struct also
this rotation period and that was
confirmed also by the results found in
the researcher more extensive work on on
this CMOS camera was performed because
we wanted to use the camera to support
the satellite laser ranging observation
actually when performing a satellite
laser ranging we know already where the
object that we want to track ISM this is
usually a genetic satellite whose
orbital really precise but nevertheless
some DFM Rize are not accurate or not
very accurate or at least not always so
the idea was to use to employ this
camera
to have a stream video and knowing the
position of the object of the laser
beams or into the camera and seeing the
position of the object we could correct
the pointing offset of our telescope
facilitating the target acquisition from
the SLR system so we needed to develop a
software that is able to communicate
with laser software send them correction
and at the same time is able to
communicate and just camera parameters
like this for time the shutter mode that
the readouts frequency if you want some
meaning we also implement some
capability to store the images and we
will see it just later why this is
important so I'll show you a screenshot
of of the software in operation and here
we have an example of the target
satellite that was topics and as later I
will talk quick quite sorry
quite often about space debris on tezo
topics in this case and as an example of
a space debris is a Defen satellite is
not operational anymore and of course
these families are not accurate anymore
actually what we see here we see on the
red cross in the image we see the
position of the laser and we see also
the position of the object as given by
the families in particular sorry the red
cross is where the families are telling
us to point while the white dot is you
see is an offset and then we were able
by clicking on the object to correct and
align the object with the laser and as
you can see in the small black window we
see some yellow dots this yellow dots
indicate that the laser pulse
was successfully detected from the laser
system and on the background they also
show the images toward the forties
object so why this is him what is nice
about this software and
what we are it's very important for us
because the this software with one
single observation session allow us to
get observation that can be used both
for the attitude and the art be
determination of the object and it is
very important for space deputy
observation not too much for improving
the laser performances as we will see
later but for space debris lay
observation is fundamental the merging
the data fusion especially when
observing from one single station so
quickly we see these are summer it is
lighter contain a summary of the
observation collected by the tracking
camera we have the position of the
object in the sky given by the directly
by the angular encoder of the telescope
and this is also an advantage because
the small field of view of the camera
and the shortest for short time
especially for Leo satellite will not
allow us to have an a-star that can be
used for classical astrometric data
reduction procedures so we have the
angular measurement and then on the top
left we see the difference between the
measured distance and the one provided
by calculated by the families at this
point is from this distance we remove
the contribution of the orbital motion
we have in the middle graph the variable
to highlight a contribution to the
measured distance given by the attitude
motion actually the laser measurement
are very precise let's say around the
centimeter accuracy and then we are able
to range to M visit in this case because
it conveys payload is a retroreflector
array this retro sectoral a is not in
the center
mass of the object and since the object
is rotating we see we are able to
evaluate the rotation of the center of
of the retroreflector around the center
of mass
finally in the last graph on the top one
on the bottom one sorry we see the
results of the analysis of the images
analyzing analyzing the brightness of
each frame we are able to structure like
or very interesting for the space debris
observation and especially for attitude
debris removal operation in future will
be the attitude the proper attitude
determination of the object so not only
the the rotation period but also the
direction of the rotation axis of the
object because in future once we want to
go and grab the object we know we should
know how to approach it and this of
these information can be retrieved by
the there are studies - on how to
retrieve this information from the data
measuring ranges and light Coast
then before moving to other application
I want to show you how the performances
of our laser software of the
performances of the laser position were
improved by and the employ of the night
of the tracking camera and over the same
amount of time we are able to shorten
the acquisition
often the time needed by the system to
to lock on the object that means we are
able to observe more object in in the
same amount of time to get more
observation and each observation has an
higher accuracy because these we don't
deliver string or observers each row
observation while we deliver what is
called the normal point the normal point
is calculated by averaging the single
observation of course the average is
more accurate the more the number of
measurements involved with
then we decided to by accident during
the doing some tests I was able to to
see a satellite during daytime so I
decided to do first some math and then I
to verify that we could see satellite
during daytime and then I did we did
some first test at noon as an example
where as the I pointed the telescope's
to different star with different
magnitude from the brightness brightest
on the left to the faintest on the right
and we that confirmed the the Matata did
and we are able to see up to magnitude 7
during full daytime the actualities
picture were acquired known something
that makes the daytime observation a bit
more difficult are the strong gradient
bright brightness gradient in the sky
toward the horizon the sky is brighter
than a drain it and of course the
brightness of the sky depend a lot also
by the distance
from the Sun and from the weather
condition dry day is better than a humid
day then okay we verified that we are
able to do something during daytime so I
decide to do some tests over satellite
here we have just a gif of that I
created using
2025 images acquired 14 satellite this
is a standard uh satellite laser ranging
target and this was observant with 0.1
seconds for sure around the sunset
what is interesting from these images is
that the if we look at the object we see
that the object is not always point like
but is changing these are the effect of
the seeing atmospheric seeing an
impressible one could do also some
research about speckles that we see then
is dressing is the how the sky bright
round is the brightness is increasing
very fast over one and a half minutes of
time interval between the first and the
last image
is sky background the sky during daytime
act as an imaginary source of light and
these are virginia source of light at
the end was showing that some some dark
spot on the camera it is not on the KY
is not due to the camera at all but it
is simply dust on the focal reducer so
to improve the quality of the image
especially the one acquired during
daytime what we can do is a set fielding
of the image this allow us to remove
some big netting and also the effect of
the dust and this improves the detect
ability of the object at the same time
also to improve in the performances
during day time we decided to analyze
the sky spectrum take into account the
transmittance II of the fog reducer and
the camera quantum efficiency so we have
everything is summarized in the plot
over here and this is the radiance of
the sky all over the morgue the visual
spectrum so in order to improve the
performance during day time we decided
to insert the long passage filters with
the cutting edge at five hundred
nanometers to cut out some of the blue
light of the sky and this allows us to
increase the signal-to-noise ratio on
the same shorts reduce the sky
background flux by something about 40%
and this translates directly into an
increase of the spotter time that can be
used to detect smaller object in the sky
oh now let me talk about some why
daytime observation why the use of day
of the tracking camera and the use of
different kind of observables is
important for the orbit determination
especially if we talk about space debris
so what we I we performed some tests we
acquired the observation during one and
two passes during daytime and one two
passes during nighttime and then we
compared it what we can get in terms of
accuracy
processing separately one two passages
possessing separated the daytime
observation with respect to the
nighttime observation then putting them
together and then we played also on the
kind of observables that we are that we
are collecting using the tracking camera
the first analysis was done on a design
and decides a standard target for the
laser community and he's allowed also
some reference orbit against which I
could compare my orbit determination
result and essentially what we can see
is that the effect of the merge merging
of the data fusion can be seen
especially for a one pass case for the
nighttime one pass case if we use only
angular observation we will have an
error over four days an average error of
100 kilometers
while if we use merchant data the error
reduces to 130 meters
then if we now instead of using only
nighttime observation during classical
space debris observation you can rely
only on nighttime observation since the
southern light has to be illuminated the
object has to be eliminated but the
observer has to be into the shadows
because they
actually this is the limit of the
technology this is a limit of the CCD
cameras that they cannot go for very
very short exposure time due to for us
an example is the problem the problem is
caused by the extra a mechanical shutter
it is solved by the CMOS that use a net
ronica shutter
then one last comparison that I want to
show you is the improvement given by the
merging daytime and nighttime
observation entities visible from the
small plot on the top where we can see
that the green and red segment are the
is the portion of arc that usually we
can observe if we rely on your nighttime
observation standing the observation to
the daytime we are able to observe
almost a quarter of an orbit and this is
translated directly into the orbit
determination accuracy
comparing one passage during nighttime
we have an accuracy again 100 kilometer
that reduce to 100 meter
even processing only angular observation
if we put together in daytime and
nightime passes the best solution that
we got was 27 meters over of average
error over four days of propagation and
this is quite important for space debris
activity since before this kind of
observation we didn't ever need a priori
information about the orbit so we could
really perform in what is called an
initial orbit determination and then
successive orbit improvement
that allowed us to reduce the covalence
and the uncertainty region of the object
position to reduce of let's say 2030
meters this is important for collision
avoidance maneuver the space is crowded
of space junk that are very dangerous
for the satellite since each and every
particle contain have an eye energy that
could potentially destroy our mission
knowing precisely where this object are
reduce the non necessary maneuvers and
enlarge the lifetime of the satellite
okay what is your telling me yes you
used the satellite that we know already
which orbit which is his orbit so we
decided to perform some tests also to
space debris
this is topics since I didn't have any
any reference orbit for this object I
needed to observe it in two consecutive
passes I use the measurement collected
during the one pass
to determine an RV that was propagated
and compared with the observation
collected during the second pass of the
satellite II always using our tracking
camera so here what we is interesting to
see is the on the Left plot we see the
rapidity
of the attitude motion and as we will
see later his object will rotate with us
with the rotation period of 10 second
and is still spinning up and his speed
is also increasing and then what is
interesting to see is that using merge
measurement we can improve our orbit
determination accuracy in by word one
order of magnitude if we look only at
the angular position by two order of
magnitude if we look at the estimation
of the distance between between the
observer and the object but is again
these are low earth satellite we could
also prove that we were able to range
also to I altitude satellite this is the
results are these observations were
collected to add debris that was former
GLONASS satellite this satellite is
orbiting at around 20,000 kilometers and
okay the improvement using merger with
respect to emergence measurement is less
evident but because we
in the distance between the two series
of observation is smaller in time and
these two series observation belongs to
the same part of the satellite
what is interesting from the left plot
is the position of the good because the
yellow point of the laser with respect
to the light curve that we are observing
actually the light curve shows some
pattern
but from the battery itself you are not
able to determine which part of the
satellite
we are currently observing and this
information is provided by the laser
we know that the retroreflector 40
satellite is in the NADA phase of the
satellite means that the the yellow
region I mean the portion of the light
coat that correspond to the yellow
region of kuniko's this is exactly D now
the phase of the satellite why it is
digression because this and let me the
connection to the measurement that can
support the attitude determination
actually knowing which is the nother
phase of the satellite we are able to to
to request to perform what is called 3
axis or the determination while the
orbit determination is other of sorry
three axis attitude determination while
the attitude determination is important
again for is important for mainly for
active debris removal mission what we
have to know from which direction is
better to approach the satellite to grab
it to the space debris to grab it and
pull it down
or if we can do also some environmental
studies here in this slide I showed you
the the light curve acquired the I
resolution light curve acquired with
CMOS camera using alpha v seconds of
exposure we were able to discriminate
some specular reflection given by the
peaks that we see in the light curve of
these rocket body is a rocket body can
be assumed as a cylindrical shaped
object so if we analyze the assuming
that this object is an affecting
condition the rotation should produce a
brightness variation that looks like a
sinusoid it is exactly what we see here
if we exclude the Maxima of the peaks
given by the specular reflection and
this is the relative minima that
probably is caused by one of the side of
the rocket bodies the field from the
light curve itself to discriminate which
is the nozzle and which is the adapter
side of the payload but what is
important is that from this measurement
we can struck the rotation period as for
the asteroid and in principle knowing
also the shape of the object one can
infer also the direction of the rotation
axis these two data
could be used to do also some
environmental studies of to evaluate
what are the torques that are acting on
a space on a spacecraft again I took
over the same example as before topics
and later we'll see iguanas to show you
how the little details that the CMOS
camera allowed to allow us to extract
from the light curve and the influence
of the change of the observation
geometry so when analyzing light cord
the position of the Sun the relative
position of the object with respect to
the Sun and the observer is important
because in relation with the attitude
motion it is the light reflected where
the observer is different it is exactly
what we see here on the bottom plot this
is the same satellite acquired in a time
distance of two days the rotation period
is pretty similar but in the first case
we see relatively flat behavior over the
pass we have only in a portion of the
past some specular reflection while on
the second pass we have an increase of
the brightness due to the crowd the
reduction of the phase angle and even if
the satellite the target satellite is
the same the features shown in the two
plots are quite different
the same is valid for the higher
altitude satellite we used an exposure
time in 0.7 seconds this time and again
this is the same rawness as before so
the two series of observation were
acquired with the distance in time of 20
minutes roughly and we can see that the
asset of the change in the observation
geometry there is on the second part on
the right claw plot we see an hour
difference a bigger difference between
the absolute Maxima absolute maximum and
the relative Maxima of the life course
but
what is interesting now what we can do
during daytime the observation geometry
and the illumination condition change
pretty fast during daytime and then here
I will report some results acquired
really during daytime on the left side
of the slide we see the results obtained
for foreign visit during daytime and
during the sunset during daytime we
didn't yet use the sky filter so the the
light curve is pretty pretty noisy
nevertheless we have some feature that
can be identified also into the second
plot a second example on the right side
is obtained for rocket stage again this
is a cylindrical object that should be
in
should rotate around it smack it maximum
axis of inertia this is an assumption we
can do since in the space there are some
dissipative torques that
let the object be great from the spin
around the minimum axis of inertia
toward the Maxim axis of inertia what is
interesting here is the change of the
observation condition relation to the
attitude motion we see at the beginning
the light core is pretty flat but then
toward the end some features start to
appear and start to be amplified this is
exactly the contribution in the
reflection given by the attitude
so that bring me to the summary so the
CMOS camera were used for a huge variety
of application from the lacking images
to the observation of asteroids we use
the tracking camera for support in
support of the we use of the CMOS camera
as tracking camera a support of SLR
observation this allows us to get
the vision for the
or simultaneously for the orbit and the
artist determination this is important
because this kind of camera could allow
us to track object that are either
yearly launch it or which re-entering in
the atmosphere where the families are of
poor accuracy we were the track the
camera allowed us to to observe light
for with an extremely high resolution
that in usual it's not possible CCD
camera and finally we were able to stand
our observation time also during daytime
and this is in the table I just put
summary of all the object advisors from
satellite to rocket stage a different
altitude that we are able to observe
only during data so that brings to that
everything from my side and thank you
for your attention and thank you Christi
for the opportunity
Thank You Emiliano for that informative
presentation now kicking off the second
part of our webinar today as dr. Amos
you've on both days
dr. Yvonne ghoulia is an astronomy
specialist at and or she studied physics
with a primary focus on astrophysics at
the University of Graz in Austria in
April two thousand eighteen she
completed her PhD thesis and multicolor
photometry of transiting extrasolar
planets in addition she has held a
research position at the Space Research
Institute and grad and spent some time
lecturing at the University of Innsbruck
for a complete biography on dr. Yvonne
booyah please visit the biography tab at
the top of your screen
unless you may now begin your
presentation
so Thank You Christy for the
introduction and thank you in Riano for
talking about the observations that you
perform at the tim evolved observatory
so my part is now to talk about Anders
camera solution for large sky surveys
and near-earth object study
so at first I would like to talk about
on this camera solutions for astronomy
in general so we have a variety of
options we offer large area and high
resolution CCD then we also have a
seamless and AM CCD camera solutions
especially for high time the solution
astronomy or if you have to deal with
low light conditions so in that case the
MCCD cameras would be the perfect
solution for you and also i would like
to highlight that we do offer camera
customizations
and just so you have an overview of
where in which projects amber is
involved in which projects om use
cameras we have for example or en CCD
cameras called the exons use as a Sofia
telescope so there they use for science
and Skype and science cameras then also
under cameras are used for exoplanet
transit observations like for terms of
the entropy s survey there to use
several icon else which are also
customized customized so those are 2 K
by 2 K CCD cameras then we have 2 silo
cameras those are FC much front
illuminated cameras used for the video
to survey so that means near of objects
Luna impacts an optical transient
studies and then we also have said what
Exxon EMC CDs used for adaptive object
optics projects like the not only
projects at the VLT I
come back to large skies base so if you
perform such surveys I would recommend
to you to use large format detectors
that is because you can make use of the
wide field of view that you can achieve
so for that we offer 2 K by 2 K
detectors up to 6 K by 6 K detectors and
that really offers you the possibility
to measure photometric variability
across a wide range of time scale for
example if you work with DVDs that
operate with a slower readout to
maintain a little noise floor that is
really great if your exposure time is in
the range of 10 to of seconds to hours
and also our CCD options for sensors
with exactly enhanced options so that is
really of advantage when you want to
observe cool objects and then if you
require high-speed observation so you
observe astronomical phenomena that
change quickly on or that change quite
hat then a new exposure time is in the
range of milliseconds to tens of seconds
then we a CMOS is the technology that I
would recommend and that you also see on
the bottom of the image on the left you
have a 14 or 40s or physical to power
and then on the right next to it is our
back illuminated 2 K by 2 K s CMOS
camera called the Madonna and I will
also talk about our new large format
camera solution of the power which you
see there on the left and on the next
slide
like to highlight again our deep cold
CCD technology so like I said this is
great if you're exposed in the range of
tens of seconds to hours those cameras
are mostly used for exoplanet
observations for example if you use
transit or RV method then also in
Whitefield spectroscopic surveys and
also gravitational lensing
now I would like to present to you some
specifications of two of our CCD cameras
that we offer we have here the icon L
and the iPhone XL the iPhone L is a 2 K
by 2 T device whereas I context L is our
4 K by 4 K device
slightly different pixel size but you
see here that through our deep cooling
down to minus hundred degree Celsius we
do offer a very very low start current
value you see it here for the iPhone
Excel for example a value of zero point
zero zero six electrons per pixel per
second and also we really offer a little
read noise of about 2.9 electrons or
three forms of these allergens and
hundred kilo Hertz and also what I would
like to highlight is that we do offer an
iPhone 6 excel as well as of 6 K by 6 K
device so that's even bigger than I
canal and I can make cell
all right so here on this slide I would
like to mention the different sensor
options that we have for I canal and I
from Excel I mentioned earlier that we
do offer new infrared sensitive sensors
receive is here and the plots you see
the quantum efficiency applauded with
some wavelengths and there we have a
comparison of three different sensors
one of the sensors is the BB that's a
standard visible sensor is so many
things of cameras and then we also have
deep depleted sensor options which
really offered if I extend this new
interventions activity so it's called
the VR DD and a big 280 sensor and also
the beach 2 DD sensor has another
coating on it and that means that we
also have an extended sensitivity and
ultraviolet and on top of this plot you
also see the peak emission of the Sun
compared to the peak emission of an
impact star called GJ 1132 so this is
the coolest R so the peak emission peak
wavelength of this star would be just
Google 900 nanometers if you want to
observe cooler objects you would really
go better with adventure options that is
near infrared sensitive
before talking about our ASIMO solutions
for large skies abase I would like to
highlight the benefits of a CMOS
detectors and the technology so what are
the characteristics these types of
detectors offer a low read noise while
simultaneously allowing to image with
high frame rates you can achieve a high
resolution they allow for a high dynamic
range there's no charge transfer and on
top of that they're not using a
mechanical shutter so this is a great
advantage if for example you're
observing from remote locations where
it's not easy to exchange a broken
mechanical shutter so a CMOS detectors
work with electronic shutters like for
example rolling and true global shutter
and all of these characteristics and
benefits of a CMOS detectors come
basically from the sensor architecture
so you see on the right hand side in the
image a comparison of the sensor
architecture between ccd and CMOS
cameras you have here mark that the
charge to voltage conversion on a CMOS
sensor takes place at each pixel whereas
and the CCD the charge is shifted from
pixel to pixel and then converted to a
voltage so because of that because of
these differences as the most detectors
can offer these specific characteristics
and I would like to highlight our a CMOS
camera so again this is great if you
want to observe with an exposure time of
milliseconds to tens of seconds so this
is usually applicable if you do in your
out near of object observations on
occupations for example corporal belt
objects or even exoplanets and it's also
great if you want to do lucky imaging or
spectral imaging
so here's an overview of some about
service that we offer you see an orange
this is the Marana it's a 2 K by 2 K
back illuminated CMOS device you really
reach of peak cords and efficiency of
about 95% I have to pause given here on
the right hand side here over two
different sensor options it comes with a
rolling each other and it offers at full
at whole frame a frame rate of about 48
frames per second and so has a little
wreath noise and then if you can also
compare that to design a 4.2 or sila 5.5
those are front illuminated as the most
cameras and the good thing for example
is that you also offer the camera link
connectivity that makes sure you can
acquire images with about hundred frames
per second and they also have
exceptional will read noise of about 0.9
allergens and then we also have two neo
five on five of the cameras that even
Jana was using for his observations and
you also mention that in presentation so
this is the front illuminated s name of
karma it's called the bit further than
the Silas and it also offers a true
global shutter which is key for several
applications
in the last but at least I would like to
highlight our newest camera developments
that have just has been launched about a
few weeks ago it is called the bowel or
this is a 40 by 40 s CMOS device it has
a 16 point 9 megapixel sensor with the
12 microns pixel size and you can really
read out really fast this is a offers
the eighteen point five new seconds
readout so you can achieve image or you
can do imaging with the full frame of 54
frames per second and you can still have
a low reason or ease of less than three
allergens so degree out of key
applications for this camera you have
object observations occupations
basically observation or large sky
surveys because like I said it's a 40 by
40 device also great for lucky and
speckle imaging or exponent studies and
even solar astronomy
so why are these wisest camera suitable
for these applications so one of the
reasons is that also like I mentioned
before that this camera is a shadow free
solution but we have electron each
others no mechanical it offers rolling
and through global shutter and
especially true global shutter is really
important for applications like solar
astronomy or orbital debris observations
then the sensor is an apparent vacuum
enclosure and this really makes sure
that the camera is a low maintenance
solution and also offers an exceptional
sensor longevity because of that this in
turn is great if you observe with that
camera from remote observing sites which
is very often the case in astronomy as
yeah it's really low maintenance and you
don't have to touch it you don't have to
do vacuum becomes nothing you don't have
to worry about the shutter then another
good thing is that you have the fast
readout but also the low noise level and
that is very different if you compare
them some CCD solutions so if you're for
example take an image you expose 10
seconds with a ccd of similar size then
you would read out in 45 seconds whereas
with the power 10 second exposure you
would read out in 18.5 milliseconds but
it was really about 2,500 times faster
than the same with a CCD and another
thing I'd like to highlight is that the
center of the power is you need to
answer it's not to pixel sense over on
whatever that we use for example for
mavala camera it is unique to Android
and just to give you some examples so
the first cameras are used at NASA JPL
or to take a solo telescope and event in
China photos are several groups that
already work with the borrower
oh yeah thank you for that please as
long as you have any questions and I
will get back to Christy
Thank You Ynez and thank you Milano for
your informative presentations we will
now start the live Q&A portion of our
webinar now to our audience if you have
any questions you'd like to ask please
do so now just click on that ask a
question box located on the far left of
your screen and we will answer as many
of your questions as we have time for
all right let's get started
our first question and enas you let's
start with you
what differentiates the Balor from the
other large area as CMOS cameras on the
market
Thank You Chrissy so that's a very good
question and I just recently did some
research on the internet and compared it
to the ball or with difference I like to
area cameras on the market and I have to
say those things that the ball is the
only camp only a CMOS camera on the
market that has a true global shutter
and as I mentioned that on my flights
earlier that is really key for several
applications like for example solar
astronomy or orbital debris observation
so that's definitely something that the
customer should keep in mind if their
application requires it's true global
shutter moment and another thing is that
I would like to highlight again that the
follower sensor is in the jamika vacuum
enclosure so that really makes sure that
the sensor is protected and offers
performance long averaged over a long
time so I think those are the main
points maybe also something that the
borrower has three different gain
options so I think that's also something
that I do not see with other large area
CMOS cameras on the market
Thanks it is now emiliana let's jump
over to you
what are limitations for the Leo
observations
oh thanks Chris is young good question
actually there are several parameters
that in that contribute to the
limitation on the Leo observation it
depend a lot on what we want to observe
so in the space debris war especially
for Leo observation and we are looking
for a small object looking for small
object and usually requires a big
aperture telescope
then the problem is like okay big
aperture telescope usually correspond to
a relatively long focal length so that
means that the field of view is small
then if you want to the discovery
becomes quite difficult and then what we
can do even if we are looking forward
this kind of object the problem is that
the smaller object need the longer
exposure time even with the bigger fill
of you then if we want to use longer
exposure time as an example we will have
a problem that following an object that
is moving fast with the longest closure
time in a small field of view either
ends up in longer star streaks in the
image and that our software is not able
to process because maybe they are not
all included in the image and secondly
is the number of stars that you see in
the image so moving the telescope faster
you will have only the brightest star in
the image but then if you have only the
brightest star and you have a small
field of view maybe you don't have
enough star in general to perform on
astrometric other reduction this is one
of them is limitation the second another
one that they would add is the time
tagging of the measurement so if you
want to do horbet determination it's
important that we are able to time tag
precisely our picture and for CCD
observation it works I would say if we
use a longer exposure time that are not
in agreement with what I have just said
so because the answer state is given by
the mechanical shutter using a
mechanical shutter usually takes 50
milliseconds to over another 50
milliseconds to close then you have
and that's a 10 to 50 millisecond when
let's say when time tanging our
measurement for a leo 50 millisecond we
are talking about how much as 7 meter
350 meter of insert uncertainty then
this is another limitation we should pay
on the millisecond level accuracy and
forties I think is easier to use an
earth triangle shutter
now emiliana while we're talking about
your telescope can you tell us what the
smallest object you can observe is okay
oh also here a nice question but there
are some parameter that one should
consider as an example we let's consider
we have different telescope here from 20
centimeter an aperture till 1 meter size
aperture depend on the of course on the
quantum efficiency depend a lot on the
sky background and let's say the average
of the telescope for the 20 centimeter
telescope doing some assumption on the
albedo on the reflectivity of the object
I would say we'd 8 seconds of exposure
we are able to get meter sized object if
we then move to the 1 meter telescope
other I'm sorry I was 4 I forgot other
parameter that influenced the the
smallest size of object that one can see
is the exposure time how much time we
are integrating and the distance of the
object so for the 20 centimeters
telescope for the 1 meter size that I
was telling you is that 36,000
kilometers at the geostationary altitude
with 8 seconds of exposure with the 1
meter telescope we are able to detect
cube shot of 10 by 10 by 10 centimeter
at 700 kilometers without for a second
of exposure and with 810 seconds of
exposure we are able to detect 20 30
centimeter at the geostationary altitude
Thank You Milian oh now eNOS let's come
over to you what is the timing accuracy
of the Bower okay yeah that's also
related to that question to that topic
so the borrower offers our HB GPS time
stamp connection and that means it
allows imaging with the GPS time steps
of a resolution of 10 nanoseconds so
that really allows you to think across
multiple instruments and multiple
observation sites so that's really a
great feature and yet the resolution is
10 nanoseconds
thank you and now our next question what
is the difference between rolling and
global shutter
yeah I guess I should have mentioned
that earlier I've been talking about
that quite a lot but yeah the difference
is that if you have rolling I will show
on each other that means that I mean the
pixels in each row are all exposed for
the same amount of time so they have the
same exposure time but the stars in the
ends of this exposure time is slightly
different with each row and in
comparison to global shutter so there
you really take a snapshot of your image
and that means that really every pixel
is exposed for the same amount of time
and at the same amount of time so that's
a slight difference but this can be
crucial for applications that really
require this kind of precise kind
correlation
Thank You Mina's now looks like we have
time for one more question
but I would like to quickly remind our
audience that any questions we did not
have time to answer today and those that
are submitted during the on-demand
period they will be addressed by our
speakers via the contact information you
provided at the time of registration and
Emiliano let's end with this question
for you what strategy do you use to
observe okay let's talk about space
debris one we have to make a distinction
even if at the end the images will look
like similar the we have to make
distinction what we want to do do we
want to discover space debris or do we
want to improve the or the accuracy of
the orbit of an object that we already
know so in the first case we are talking
about survey in a survey usually we
point the telescope in the sky the
region of the skies usually is not
completely random but usually you look
to particular region that should be
populated by the Bream and populated by
certain kind of debris as an example if
you want to do just a tional survey of
the debris we point around the
gestational e belt and we simulate the
motion of the object so for the
geostationary belt is easy because you
point the telescope in the sky you don't
compensate for the rotation of the earth
so that you de say the object will
reflect the light always on the same
pixel that is allow us to improve the
signal-to-noise ratio then usually a
survey strategy is done in a way that
whis can sense this as an example of
orbit of the geostationary belt without
trying without losing any object that is
passing through
and then with can different senses over
the Geo belt so that we in a way that we
should be able to observe the same
object a couple of time two or three
times during the same night because this
is a key number to estimate the
relatively good initial orbit
determination if we are talking about an
object that we already know we point the
telescope into the sky where the object
should be a disability precise epoch and
we move the telescope according to the
orbital motion of the object these allow
us still to maximize the signal-to-noise
ratio of the object because the job to
reflect the light always on the same
side of the camera but then here the
strategy can it can be more complex
either there are studies an example of
colleagues that are plane are planning
these follow-up observation that are
used for a bit improvement in order to
minimize the time component of the
covariance matrix given by the previous
orbit the finish result
thank you now before we go I want to
make sure to thank the audience for
joining us today and for their
interesting questions and those
questions we did not have time for today
and those submitted during the on demand
period will be addressed by our speakers
the other contact information you
provided at the time of registration I
would once again like to thank dr.
Emiliano Craig le and dr. en su von boo
you for joining us today and for their
interesting research I'd also like to
thank lab roots and our sponsor and or
for underwriting today's educational
webcast this webcast can be viewed
on-demand and laberd's will alert you
via email when it's available for replay
we encourage you to share that email
with your colleagues who may have missed
today's live event that's all for now
and we hope to see you again soon have a
great day